SCOTT ELLIS: Hello, my
name is Scott Ellis.
And I'm a Product
Manager on Google Cloud.
And today, we're going to talk
about managing sensitive data
in hybrid environments.
What we're going to cover
today is a quick overview
of our Cloud data loss
prevention or DLP platform.
And then we're
going to go and see
how we can use DLP in
hybrid environments.
And after that, we're going
to show a demo of this
by using DLP to inspect data
into MySQL database that's
running in a virtual machine.
And then we're going to migrate
some of that data into BigQuery
and use DLP again to do data
masking or data redaction.
Let's get started.
So first an overview of our
data loss prevention platform.
First we feel that
protecting sensitive data
really begins with knowing
where that data exists.
And so one of the core
features of our platform
is discovery and classification.
And our data loss
prevention platform,
again, is fully
managed service that
helps you discover,
classify, and protect
your most sensitive data.
And we do this, again, through
discovery, classification,
as well as a set of tools
called de-identification,
which is a way to transform
or mask sensitive data.
And this platform
is built to work
on structured data,
unstructured data,
as well as workloads that
might be in real time,
or at rest or in batch.
To cover this in more detail,
when we talk about discovery
and classification of
sensitive data, what we mean
is being able to look at data
and identify different elements
inside that data that
might be sensitive.
An example of that
could be things
like personally identifiable
information or PII.
This would be things like names,
dates of birth, credit card
numbers, and a variety
of different things.
And we have different
types out of the box
that we support that
are both global,
as well as country
specific identifiers.
We also have some
special categories
like credentials and
secrets that help look
for things like
passwords or off tokens
whether it be on our
cloud or other clouds.
And these are things that
might not identify a person,
but are sensitive and
might give a credential
or access to privileged
access to resources.
You can also
customize all of this
either by defining your
own info type detectors
or by using detection rules to
change how our detectors work
or to tune them for your needs.
That second set of
capabilities, again, we
call de-identification.
It's often referred to as
things like data masking
or tokenization.
And this is where we go
in and actually manipulate
the data to try to de-risk
it or obfuscate it somehow.
And as you can see in this
before-and-after animation,
what we're doing is we're
applying those techniques
to different columns
in this table.
In the first three
columns, we are
applying a technique
that basically
transforms the entire column.
And then in that fourth
column, the comments field,
we're actually using a
combination of our inspection
and our masking to look
for data inside of the cell
and only redact that item.
So you see in that first row, we
actually find an email address.
Instead of removing the entire
cell or the entire comment,
we just remove
that email address
and leave the rest intact.
So that's an example how
we combine our inspection
and our de-identification
to work on unstructured data
or semi structured data.
And where this may be
applicable or where
you might use this,
one example, is
to help prevent exposure of
raw secrets or sensitive data.
So imagine, again, you had,
let's say, your public website
or your company website, and
all of those public assets
were hosted in a
Cloud storage bucket.
And these are assets
that power your website
that are generally
available to anyone when
they're viewing your website.
But what happens if
somebody uploads something
into that bucket or into that
folder that shouldn't be there?
Maybe it's sensitive.
So running something like an
inspection scan of that bucket,
we could identify, for example,
here if somebody uploaded a GCP
credential into that bucket,
which again, you would not
want to expose that publicly
as it could give [INAUDIBLE]
access to some of
your resources.
Another example would
be to unblock workloads.
Maybe it's a machine learning
or artificial intelligence
workload, or some sort of
a cloud migration workload.
And here we would
look at moving data
into those different
environments
and applying that
de-identification
to obscure or mask
the data, but still
allow that analysis or that
machine learning to happen.
Another use case
would be really just
to understand and classify data
across your entire enterprise.
And our cloud platform
has an API arrest
or a gRPC API that
enables you to call it
from virtually anywhere.
And that's what we're going to
focus on in the next section
is how we can use this
in hybrid environments
that may be on or off Cloud
or on or off Google Cloud.
And let's get into that.
So what do we actually mean
by hybrid environments?
Well, really, we're
thinking of, again,
taking those core capabilities
around inspection,
classification, and
masking, and applying it
on data that might be on other
Clouds, might be on premise,
could be in non-native
storage systems.
This could be like a database
that you're running inside
of a virtual machine.
Maybe it's running
inside of an application
like a web or a mobile app.
Or it could, of course, be
running on Google Cloud.
So a few examples of that.
Maybe you want to
inspect data that's
running in something
like AWS's RDS system,
or maybe it's in MySQL
database running inside
of a virtual machine, or
again, a database that's
running on premise.
We're actually going to
show a demo of this later,
looking at MySQL running
in a virtual machine.
Maybe you want to
inspect and tokenize data
as you're migrating
that data from on prem
into Cloud or between
environments like production,
development, and analytics.
Another example could be
inspecting and redacting
transactions from a web
or mobile application
before you store
that data at rest.
So to do this, we're going to
talk about two of our methods.
These are two methods on
our Cloud DLP platform.
One called content methods
and one called hybrid method.
Now hybrid methods
are a newer method
that we've released recently.
But let's go over
both of these methods.
So first content methods.
You'll notice
actually that these
are pretty similar as
far as the data sources
that they apply to.
This could be data
running on any cloud,
on premise, and virtually
any data source.
But with content
methods, it's what
we call a synchronous
request and response.
These are methods where
you make a request.
You send data in that request.
And you get a response
back in that request.
And that response is the answer.
It's the classification
or the mass data.
These methods are
stateless and they
allow both inspection and
de-identification capabilities.
Now our new hybrid
methods are similar
but a little bit different.
What they do is they
actually take your data.
They allow you to
do a fire and forget
where you can send this
data in for inspection
but then move on.
You don't have to
wait for the response
or process the response.
In here, DLP will
aggregate that data
and put it together
and aggregate it
so that you can store
that data or analyze it,
for example, in
something like BigQuery
or make reports of
Data Studio, or publish
other types of alerts.
And for now, this is
only for inspection.
And that's what we're going
to talk about later and demo
this later as well, how we
can take information, send it
through these hybrid methods,
and then produce an audit
report using BigQuery
and Data Studio.
But again, these
are the two methods
you would use to handle
data in hybrid environments.
And here's an example
of what that audit
report might look like.
So again, imagine
you're scanning data
across several
different assets and you
want to collect all
of this in one place,
analyze it using
BigQuery or visualize it
in some sort of audit report
like we're showing here, using
something like Data Studio.
In this example, we're showing
several different things
that we've inspected.
And as you see,
we're getting results
about what kind of
database we looked
at, what tables and columns
and DLP findings we have there.
Now, another aspect to this is
what we call regionalization.
And with DLP, you also
have regional endpoints.
And this means that you
can actually specify where
your data is being processed.
So for example, let's say
you want to inspect data
from on premise.
But you want to make sure that
the inspection part that's
running on our
platform is limited
to a particular location.
Maybe you want all your
data to stay in Australia
or in Europe or in the US.
You can specify a
regional endpoint,
which means that your data will
be processed in that region.
And it gives you the control
of whether you're doing it
for data residency
purposes or you're
planning out an availability
or a performance or latency
requirement.
You can pick those regional
endpoints if you need to.
Great, now let's go in and go
a little bit deeper on what
these hybrid methods look like.
So when we use the new
hybrid method, what we do
is we created a hybrid job.
In this job, it really
is an active listener
that's going to be
listening for requests
and then aggregating all
those findings for you
so that you can come back
later and see the results.
And when we define
this request, we're
going to basically create a job
instead of specifying a storage
location like Cloud
storage or BigQuery.
We would pick a storage
location of hybrid.
We would then provide additional
metadata for that job.
Now this metadata is important
because that's the information
that we're going to use to
aggregate everything together.
You can specify some of
that in the actual job
or in each request.
And let's go into a little
bit more detail of what
a request might look like.
So here is an actual
code sample where
we're showing what
a hybrid inspection
request would look like.
On the right side,
we're actually--
this is a code sample in Java.
And what we're showing
here at the top
is there's some content
that we want to inspect.
In this case, we're going to
be inspecting tabular data.
So we've provided headers
and rows of that data.
Then we have our hybrid,
our actual hybrid request.
In this case, that's
where we're supplying
all of those details
and all that metadata
that we want to
aggregate around.
So here's where we would pass
it things like a MySQL database
type or a version, or maybe
a database name or table name
because we want to add those
things to our report later on.
And then we send the request.
And in this example
again, this is just
showing the snippet
that will basically
provide all that information
and send that request in.
And then on the server side,
DLP will inspect that data,
aggregate it together, and allow
you to then go in and analyze
that information using something
like the BigQuery or Data
Studio.
Great, now that we've shown
you what a request looks like,
let's move into an
actual demo of this.
And what we're going
to show in this demo
is we're going to
scan data that's
running in a MySQL
database that is
running on a virtual machine.
We're going to
inspect that data.
And then we're going to
migrate one of those tables
over to BigQuery, using
DLP again to do masking.
So we basically can
protect that data
as we're migrating it
from this virtual machine
into a managed
service like BigQuery.
Great.
Let's get started on the demo.
We're going to show
a demo in two parts.
In part one, we're
going to inspect data
from a MySQL database that's
running in a virtual machine.
And to do this, we're going
to use a custom script that's
going to read this information,
send it into our Cloud data
loss prevention platform,
using the Hybrid inspection
method, which is going to
then write data into BigQuery.
And we're going to visualize
that in Data Studio.
The second part, we're going to
migrate a table from that MySQL
database using Cloud DLP
and Dataflow to tokenize
that data as we move
it into BigQuery
and migrate it from
MySQL into BigQuery.
Let's get started.
Great, the first thing
we're going to do
is create a new hybrid job.
To do that, I've navigated to
security and then Data Loss
Prevention in the Cloud console.
And now I'm going
to click on Create
and then Job, provide
a name for the job,
and then pick a storage
location of Hybrid.
Now Hybrid, again,
means that it's going
to create an active listener.
It's going to be listening
for request streams.
Each of those
requests streams will
include the content
that we want to inspect
as well as any labels
that act as metadata.
So again, these labels can
define the type of data
that we're scanning,
maybe a database.
And our demo will be a MySQL
database, the database name,
and the table name.
Now we can put
require labels here,
which means every
request is required
to have that label
filled out, as well
as optional labels that we
can apply it to job level,
but that can be overridden
by each request.
Now the rest of this
job configuration
is similar to other job types.
I define the types of things
that I want to look for,
either by using a template or
by putting the configuration
as I have here in the job.
Then when I'm done, I
simply click create.
Great, now that we have our
job, we're ready to use it.
So I switched environments
here to a project
that is running our MySQL VM.
Now in this case, we've
chosen to use Google's Compute
Engine to host the MySQL
instance and run the script.
But again, this could be
a VM running anywhere,
either clouds on premise.
And again, the script
here that we're running
is connecting to the database
using a standard JDBC protocol.
And so we're in the VM.
Let's go ahead and just see
what kind of data we have here.
What I'm doing here is
I'm just simply selecting
a database called company 2.
And then we are seeing the
tables that are in there.
It looks like we've got
a handful of tables.
And we're going to use DLP
to inspect these tables.
Now in the job, we've configured
it to write and save findings
into to BigQuery.
And so that allows us
to then go do analysis
either in BigQuery using SQL
or in a tool like Data Studio
where we can visualize things.
Great, let's get started.
So we're going to
run a script here.
Now this script
again, is just going
to look at the information,
stream a sample.
In this case, we've set the
limit to 10,000 rows per table.
It's going to stream
a sample of that data,
DLP's going to inspect it, and
then generate those findings.
Also note here
that even though we
have a user name and a
password in this command line,
that's not the actual
database password.
We are using our
Secrets Manager,
which is a tool that allows
you to protect enterprise
and production secrets
in instances like this.
So as you see we're
running the script here.
And you see that little note
here retrieving password
from Cloud Secret Manager.
And we're writing this script.
And in just a few
seconds, we've gone
through all the different
tables, read a sample,
and done some inspection here.
And again, we named
this next 2020 demo 1.
So when we go into our report,
let's look for that data.
I'm going to switch over
here to Data Studio.
Now this is a report we've been
using for a lot of test runs.
So we already have data in here.
And now we've run test runs on
local instances, ones running
in Compute Engine, ones
running in different systems
from other clouds here,
as well as even running
against systems
like BigQuery, which
also have a JDBC connector.
So again, it's a very
versatile script.
And again, leveraging
our hybrid methods,
we're able to see
all of this data
from several different runs all
collected in this audit report.
But I'm going to go ahead
and refresh the data here.
And let's see if our demo
data is available yet.
So again, we sent those
sample data into DLP.
It inspected it.
Now we're just refreshing to
see if that data is available.
OK, so we see here.
We have next 2020 demo 1.
Let's click there and see if
we can see any findings here.
It looks like we found
90,000 different things.
Again, sending 10,000
rows per table,
there could be multiple
findings per row.
So that's probably where
we got into the 90,000.
Great.
So we see a couple
different tables here.
And we're going to look at
this first one, the CARS table.
Again, as we see here,
it looks like we were
running MySQL version here.
Again, we scan
database company 2.
It looks like we found
something in the CARS table.
We found a VIN number
and an email address.
So again, this is
just a quick way
to show the power of hybrid.
So what we did is
we ran the script,
streamed in a sample of data.
And within a few seconds,
we scanned all the tables.
And a few seconds later that
data was inspected by DLP
and made available through
BigQuery and Data Studio
for reporting.
Now, again, for part
two, we're going
to actually take some of
that data from that database
and migrate it into BigQuery
and use Cloud DLP to tokenize
that data along the way.
So if you remember,
we found we're going
to use this CARS table here.
And if you remember, we found
sensitive data, VIN number,
and email address.
So what we're going to
do is we're actually
going to migrate that data.
So we're going to
export it from MySQL.
And we're going to
use a pipeline that
is powered by data flow in
order to process that data
and ingest it into BigQuery.
Now, one of the first things
that we were going to do
is define exactly what
we want to de-identify.
So to do that, we're going
to navigate back over
to our security and data
loss prevention in the Cloud
console.
And we're going to create a
de-identification template.
So I click here on create.
Go to template.
We're going to do a
de-identification template.
Now de-identification
is a term that's
really to a collection
of techniques
to transform this data.
And in this case, we're going
to do a record transformation.
And let's just call
this test DID2.
[INAUDIBLE] here.
Now when we're doing a record
transformation, what that means
is that we're going to
apply transformations
on an entire column.
Now we can leverage our info
type inspection as well,
and that's the thing that we
use to find out the number
and find that email.
But in this case, we've
already done that.
If you remember, we had a
column called VIN and email
that had sensitive data in it.
So we're just going to
create a simple template here
for the field VIN and email.
We're going to do what's called
a primitive transformation.
So we're not going to rely on
it finding the email and the VIN
because we already know
that column has it.
And we're going to
simply go in and we're
going to do a deterministic
token or shoot optimization.
What that's going to do is
convert the VIN and the email
into a token that keeps
deterministic and referential
integrity.
Then I'm going to cancel
this because I've already
created that template that we're
going to use, which is listed
here as next 2020 CARS DID 1.
Now I'm going to navigate
over to data flow.
Now, in data flow, we've
actually already got
this pipeline running.
But just to show you
how we got there,
we'll click on Create
Job from template.
We name our job.
This will be test job 1.
And we actually pick an
existing template here
called masking tokenization
for Cloud DLP to BigQuery.
This is going to ask us
for a few parameters.
Again, it wants to know
the path that we're
going to land or drop
our CSV files into,
where do we want to
injest them into BigQuery.
And again, that reference
to that de-identification
template that we just created.
So again, filling this
out, clicking run job,
that's how we get
this pipeline started.
Let's actually go and show
this pipeline in action.
So I've got this
pipeline running here.
And I've also got
the bucket that I'm
using to ingest this data.
Now, we already downloaded or
pulled that data out of MySQL.
And so just for the purpose of
this demo, what I'm going to do
is go ahead and
upload that file.
Great, so we just uploaded a
very small sample of this file.
Again, we're trying to show
that end-to-end workflow here.
As we see here, it's
pulling for the input file.
It looks like we
processed some files here.
We've run some tokenization.
I'm going to go over
to BigQuery here.
Let's just refresh this.
So we can pull up that
data set that we're
writing the results to.
And let's see if it's there yet.
OK, great, so you see
here we have a CARs
table that's just been created.
Let's just go look
at a preview here.
And as you can see, the email
address and the VIN number
have both been obfuscated
and basically identified.
So that we're protecting
that information.
What this means is someone
can now analyze this data
that we've extracted and moved
over from that MySQL database
without revealing
the email address.
But they can still do joins.
They can still do
aggregate because we've
chosen to use a deterministic
tokenization method that
preserves that integrity.
So again, the same email
gets the same token.
The same VIN number
gets the same token,
but we're not revealing the
underlying sensitive data.
And this concludes the
second part of our demo
where we wanted to show a
hybrid migration taking data
from a hybrid system,
in this case MySQL,
and migrating that into Cloud.
In this case, into
BigQuery, using Cloud
DLP to protect that data
through tokenization
and de-identification.
Thanks again for your time.
Great, well, I hope
that demo showed you
some of the power of Cloud
DLP and how you can use
that in hybrid environments.
For more details,
check out the link
below where you can learn
about our data loss prevention
platform, as well
as see more examples
and use cases for how to apply
DLP both on Cloud and off Cloud
in these hybrid environments.
Thank you again.